I want to play you this moment that happened to get captured on tape. But to fully appreciate this moment, you need a little background. This was recorded in Hoboken, New Jersey. And Hoboken is this old city on the water with these tiny, narrow streets. And because of the way the streets are laid out, parking is just a huge issue there. It is always impossible to find a parking space. And they'll ticket you if you go just an inch or two into a no parking zone. Very strict, that is, for most people. Some people, apparently, never get tickets.
我想给你听听这段被录下来的片段。但要充分体会这一刻的意义，你需要了解一点背景。这段录音是在新泽西州的霍博肯录制的。霍博肯是一座依水而建的古老城市，街道非常狭窄。因为街道布局的原因，停车在那里成了巨大的难题。找停车位永远是不可能的任务。如果你哪怕只把车停进禁停区一两英寸，他们都会给你开罚单。这非常严格，我是说，对大多数人来说是这样。但显然，有些人从来没收到过罚单。
And a couple years ago, this started to bother a woman named Kathy Mallow. She was outside on the sidewalk a lot walking her dogs. And she kept seeing this car belonging to this B-list character actor who's in the movies. And this car would always be parked in front of this one Italian restaurant, blatantly illegal, over and over. And when she would go to the cops about this, they did nothing, which was, of course, infuriating, and seemed so unfair. And not really knowing what else to do, she started photographing the actor's car. So she all of these photos taken over the course of months-- this car sitting there, illegal, no ticket. She became, really, kind of obsessed. Her nickname now in Hoboken is the Hoboken Hall Monitor. It's really at a point where she worries sometimes that she comes off as a crazy person. OK, that's the setup. That brings us to this tape.
几年前，这件事开始困扰一位叫凯西·马洛的女士。她经常在人行道上遛狗。她不断看到一辆属于某位电影界二线性格演员的车。这辆车总是违章停在一家意大利餐厅门前，非常明目张胆，一次又一次。当她向警察反映这个问题时，他们什么都没做，这当然让人非常愤怒，也显得非常不公平。由于不知道还能做什么，她开始拍摄这位演员的车。于是，她在几个月的时间里拍下了所有这些照片——这辆车一直停在那里，违章，却没收到罚单。她真的变得有点痴迷了。她现在在霍博肯的绰号是“霍博肯大厅监督员”。有时候她甚至担心自己看起来像个疯子。好吧，这就是背景。这就引出了这段录音。
Hey, Ron. How are you?
嘿，罗恩。你好吗？
Good, how are you? How's everything? How's the cat?
挺好的，你呢？一切都好吗？猫怎么样了？
Kathy is walking down the street. And she's the kind of person who knows everybody she passes on the street.
凯西正走在街上。她是那种认识路上遇到的每一个人的人。
Is that Tessa?
那是苔丝吗？
Yes.
是的。
Hi, Tessa.
嗨，苔丝。
And she's with her neighbor, Tracy. Tracy Roland is a reporter. And Tracy is rolling tape because she is asking Kathy to explain about the movie actor's car.
她和邻居特雷西在一起。特雷西·罗兰是一位记者。特雷西正在录音，因为她让凯西解释关于那位电影演员车子的事。
I would see it every day at the same time because-- oh here's a parking utility guy. What's he doing?
我每天都能在同一时间看到它，因为——哦，那是停车管理员。他在干什么？
What he's doing is parking his black city SUV. This is an official vehicle, marked Hoboken Parking Utility-- that's the Hoboken parking police-- in an unmistakable no-parking yellow zone, on the Northeast corner of 1st and Bloomfield. And then, the guy, who is in uniform with a badge, gets out and walks to a bar.
他在做的是把他的黑色城市SUV停下来。这是一辆公务车，上面标着“霍博肯停车管理”——也就是霍博肯的停车警察——停在第一街和布卢姆菲尔德街东北角一个显眼的黄色禁停区。然后，那个穿着制服、戴着徽章的人下了车，走进了一家酒吧。
He's leaving his illegally-parked vehicle.
他要把他的违章车辆丢在那儿了。
Do you want to ask him about it?
你想问问他吗？
Yeah. Do you want to ask him about it?
是啊。你想问问他关于这件事吗？
Yeah. OK.
好，没问题。
Hi. Do you mind answering a question about your car?
嗨。你介意回答一个关于你车子的问题吗？
I'm sorry. I can't.
抱歉，我不能。
Do you want to tell us--
你想告诉我们——
Why is your parking utility van parked so illegally, including into the pedestrian crosswalk?
为什么你的停车管理车停得这么违法，甚至停进了行人横道里？
I'm running in there. I'm going to tell my friend something. Is that all right with you?
我正要跑进去。我要去告诉我的朋友一件事。这没问题吧？
Oh, OK. Going into Buskers to talk to a friend. Nice.
哦，好的。进Buskers酒吧去和朋友说话。真不错。
Yeah, to talk to my friend.
是的，去和我的朋友说话。
Great. We were just wondering why the parking authority is parking illegally.
太棒了。我们只是好奇为什么停车管理局的车在违法停车。
I didn't do nothing wrong.
我没做错任何事。
Oh, you don't think that's wrong to have your vehicle parked illegally like that?
哦，你不觉得像那样违法停车是错误的吗？
Not at all. It's fine.
一点也不。这没问题。
Your vehicle is fine? Your vehicle is into the pedestrian crosswalk, and your vehicle--
你的车没问题？你的车停进了人行横道里，而且你的车——
No, it's not. No, it's not. If you go over there and look, you're going to see it's not in the pedestrian crosswalk.
不，它没有。不，它没有。如果你过去看看，你会发现它并没有停在人行横道里。
And how far is it from the curb?
离路边有多远？
It's fine, though. Is it blocking the crosswalk, though?
它停得没问题。它挡住人行横道了吗？
Yes. And it's parked illegally.
是的。而且它是违法停车。
You think so. So go walk right over there and I bet you won't get [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
你认为是这样。那你走过去看看，我敢打赌你不会被开罚单的。
OK, thanks a lot. Thanks a lot for taking on really conscientious responsible behavior. I really like paying your salary.
好的，多谢了。非常感谢你展现出这种尽职负责的行为。我真的很喜欢付你的工资。
You're very sarcastic, ma'am.
女士，你非常尖酸刻薄。
I really like paying your salary.
我真的很喜欢付你的工资。
You really have problems with yourself.
你真是有心理问题。
I really like paying your salary.
我真的很喜欢付你的工资。
You really have problems with yourself. Get a life.
你真是有心理问题。找点正事干吧。
No, I think you have problems taking responsibility.
不，我觉得你有逃避责任的问题。
Get a life.
找点正事干吧。
I hope you could hear that last part. After she says, I really like paying your salary, he says, get a life.
希望你能听到最后那部分。在她说了“我真的很喜欢付你的工资”之后，他说，“找点正事干吧”。
See? He completely denied that he was parked illegally. Imagine that--
看到了吗？他完全否认了自己是违章停车。想象一下——
Well, you know--
嗯，你知道——
--over and over and over again. And then, that is the same thing that I get when I've addressed it before-- get a life. Like somehow, if you notice this sort of thing and you want the rules to be enforced correctly, you're somehow supposed to get a life. And you're just not supposed to question the sense of entitlement.
——一次又一次。这和我之前提到这事时得到的回答一模一样——“找点正事干吧”。好像如果你注意到了这种事，并且希望规则能被正确执行，你就应该“找点正事干”。而你根本不应该质疑这种理所当然的特权感。
Yes, it's just parking. But what kills Kathy is how blatant it is. Right there on the street, this daily proof that everybody does not have to obey the same rules. Who do they think they are? Well, today on our radio show, it is an unfair world. And sometimes it makes you crazy, the things that people above you get away with. And then, something happens like, for example, a black man becomes president of the United States, just to choose an example at random. And really, you would have to have a heart of stone not to feel hopeful.
是的，这只是停车问题。但让凯西抓狂的是这种明目张胆的程度。就在街上，这种每日可见的证据表明并非每个人都必须遵守同样的规则。他们以为自己是谁？好了，今天在我们的电台节目里，这是一个不公平的世界。有时候，那些身居高位的人所逃脱的惩罚会让你发疯。然后，发生了一些事情，比如，一个黑人成为了美国总统，这只是随手举个例子。说真的，除非你的心是石头做的，否则你不可能不感到希望。
And so today, in this historic week, we have stories of insiders and outsiders, the haves and the have nots, and people staring across the divide between the two groups, trying to figure it out. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in three acts. Act One, Hard Times, we have voices from our country's past when lots of haves got turned into have nots. Act Two, we talk a little about Tuesday. Act Three, Putting the Cart Before the Porsche. In that act, reflections on a life at the top from a teenager who was there. Stay with us.
所以今天，在这个历史性的一周，我们有关于圈内人和圈外人、富有者和贫困者的故事，还有人们注视着这两个群体之间的鸿沟，试图弄清楚这一切。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，艰难时期，我们将听到国家过去的声音，那时许多富有者变成了贫困者。第二幕，我们谈谈周二的事。第三幕，本末倒置。在那一幕中，我们将听到一位曾经置身顶层的青少年对那种生活的反思。请继续收听。
Act One, Hard Times. A week ago, Studs Terkel died. He was 96. Oral histories were around before Studs started doing them, but he pretty much redefined them and did them so amazingly well that anybody who comes after can't help but be influenced. When Studs did an interview, it was history, and it was character study, and it was dramatic storytelling, and it was entertainment all rolled up into one. We all stand in his shadow, all of us who pull out tape recorders and talk to people who aren't famous or powerful or newsworthy in the normal sense.
第一幕，艰难时期。一周前，斯塔兹·特克尔去世了。他享年96岁。在斯塔兹开始做口述历史之前，这种形式就已经存在了，但他基本上重新定义了它，并且做得如此出色，以至于任何后继者都无法不受他的影响。当斯塔兹进行采访时，那是历史，是性格研究，是戏剧性的叙事，也是娱乐，所有这些融为一体。我们所有拿出录音机去采访那些并非著名、并非强大、也非新闻人物的普通人时，都站在他的阴影之下。
Around the country, if you've heard of Studs, it's because of his books-- Division Street, The Good War, Working. But he was a radio man. In Chicago, you could hear him on the radio for most of his career at WMFT, and in the last decade, at the radio station our show comes from, WBEZ. Today, in remembrance, we bring you some of the interviews that he collected for his book about the Great Depression, Hard Times. This historic week, when another Chicagoan made some news, it has really been a pleasure to listen to these voices from the past talking about the sweep of change that this country has gone through. These were first broadcast as a 12-part series back in 1971, though Studs had been gathering these interviews for years, preparing for his book. Anyway, here he is.
在全国各地，如果你听说过斯塔兹，那是因为他的书——《分界街》、《好战争》、《工作》。但他是个广播人。在芝加哥，你在他职业生涯的大部分时间里都能在WMFT电台听到他的声音，而在过去十年里，则是在我们节目的来源地，WBEZ电台。今天，为了纪念他，我们为你带来他为关于大萧条的著作《艰难时期》所收集的一些采访。在这个历史性的一周，当另一位芝加哥人制造了一些新闻时，听听这些来自过去的声音，谈论这个国家所经历的巨大变迁，真是种享受。这些采访最初是1971年作为12集系列节目播出的，尽管斯塔兹多年来一直在收集这些采访，为他的书做准备。不管怎样，他来了。
In recalling an epoch some 30, 40 years ago, my colleagues experienced pain in some instances, acceleration in others. And often, it was a fusing of both. A hesitancy at first was followed by a flow of memories, long ago hurts and small triumphs, honors and humiliations. And there was an occasional laughter, too. Are they telling the truth, these oral historians? The question is as academic as the day Pontius Pilate asked it, his philosophy not quite washing out his guilt.
在回忆大约三四十年前的那个时代时，我的同仁们有的感受到了痛苦，有的感受到了加速。通常，这是两者的融合。最初的犹豫之后，是一连串的记忆，久远的伤害和微小的胜利，荣誉和屈辱。偶尔还有笑声。他们说的是实话吗，这些口述历史记录者？这个问题就像本丢·彼拉多提问那天一样学术，他的哲学并没有洗刷掉他的罪恶感。
It's the question Pa Joad asked of Preacher Casy, when the ragged man, in a tranchant camp poured out his California agony in the novel Grapes of Wrath. Pa said, "Suppose he's telling the truth, that fellow?" The preacher answered, "He's telling the truth, all right. The truth for him. He wasn't making nothing up." "How about us?" Tom Joad demanded. "Is that the truth for us?" "I don't know," said Casy. "I suspect the preacher spoke for those whose voices you hear, in their rememberings are their truths. The precise fact, or the precise date, is of small consequence. It's simply an attempt to get the story of a holocaust, known as the Great Depression, from an improvised battalion of survivors."
这正是保罗·乔德在小说《愤怒的葡萄》中问传教士凯西的问题，当时那个衣衫褴褛的人在营地里倾诉着他在加州的痛苦。保罗说：“假设他说的是真的，那个家伙？”传教士回答说：“他说的是真话，没错。对他来说是真的。他没有编造任何东西。”“我们呢？”汤姆·乔德追问道。“那是我们的真相吗？”“我不知道，”凯西说。我怀疑传教士代表了那些你们听到声音的人，在他们的回忆里就是他们的真相。确切的事实或确切的日期并不重要。这仅仅是一种尝试，从一群即兴的幸存者那里获取关于一场被称为“大萧条”的大灾难的故事。
If I say to you the Great Depression--
如果我对你说大萧条——
Oh, this suggests struggle. This suggests struggle for survival, survival just to be warm. To have bread and Karo syrup was a treat. Anything you brought in the house that was food, [SPEAKING CROATIAN] did it cost a lot?
哦，这让人想到挣扎。这让人想到为了生存而挣扎，仅仅为了保暖而生存。能有面包和卡罗糖浆就是一种享受。任何你带进屋里的食物，[克罗地亚语]，这花费很多吗？
Was that a Croatian phrase?
那是克罗地亚语吗？
Yes. No matter what you brought in, if you brought bread and eggs and Karo syrup. I don't remember so much my going to the store and buying food. I must have been terribly proud, and felt I can't do it. But how early we all stayed away from going to the store. Because we sensed that my father didn't have the money. And so we stayed hungry. And then I can think of when the WPA, the Workman's Project Administration, came in. And my father immediately got employed on the WPA.
是的。无论你带什么回来，哪怕是面包、鸡蛋和卡罗糖浆。我不太记得我去商店买食物的事。我一定是非常自豪，觉得自己做不到。但我们很早就学会了不去商店。因为我们感觉到我父亲没有钱。所以我们保持饥饿。然后我可以想到WPA，即工程进度管理局出现的时候。我父亲立刻在WPA找到了工作。
And I remember how stark it was for me to come into training and have girls-- one of them, who lived across the hall from me at Patton Memorial, whose father was a doctor in Michigan-- I can think of people and how it struck me of their impression of the WPA. Because before I could ever say my father was employed on the WPA, discussions and bull sessions in our rooms immediately was, these lazy people that don't do a thing, the shovel-leaners. And I'd just sit there and listen to them. And then I'd look around, and I realized, sure, your father's a doctor in St. Joe, Michigan. Well, how nice. In my family, there was no respectable employment. There was no-- until I thought, you don't know what it's like.
我记得我刚开始训练时是多么深刻，当时有女孩们——其中一个住在巴顿纪念馆我对门，她的父亲是密歇根州的医生——我能想起人们对WPA的印象。因为在我说出我父亲在WPA工作之前，我们在房间里的讨论和谈话立刻就是，这些人是懒惰的，什么都不做，是“靠着铲子的人”。我就坐在那里听她们说。然后我环顾四周，我意识到，确实，你的父亲是圣约瑟夫的医生，密歇根州。嗯，那很好。在我的家庭里，没有体面的工作。直到我想，你不知道那是什么感觉。
My father had a restaurant.
我父亲开了一家餐馆。
This was where?
是在哪里？
This was in Arkansas. And when I knew the Depression had really hit with full impact, the electric lights went off. Parents could no longer pay the $1 electric bill, which had amounted to, maybe for a month or two months, $1.80 at the most. And kerosene lamps went up in the home and in the business. Over each individual table in the restaurant, there was a kerosene lamp. This did something to me. Because it let me know that my father wasn't the greatest cat in the world, and I had always thought he was, you know. But it also let me know that he could adjust to any situation. And he taught us how to adjust to situations.
在阿肯色州。当我意识到大萧条真正全面爆发时，电灯熄灭了。父母再也付不起1美元的电费，那电费最多也就1.80美元一个月或两个月。家里和店里都换上了煤油灯。餐馆里的每张桌子上都有一盏煤油灯。这对我产生了一些影响。因为它让我知道我父亲并不是世界上最了不起的人，而我一直认为他是，你知道的。但它也让我知道他可以适应任何情况。他教会了我们如何适应环境。
Now, we were fortunate compared to the situation of other people. We always had food. There was never any money, but who needed money then? The restaurant went right through the Depression. We were selling hamburgers for a nickel, Studs. My father would have a meal ticket. You could get a full-course meal-- that is, meat and three vegetables-- for $0.25.
现在，比起其他人的情况，我们很幸运。我们总是有食物。虽然从来没有钱，但那时谁需要钱呢？餐馆一直经营到了大萧条时期。我们以五分钱的价格卖汉堡，斯塔兹。我父亲会有一张餐券。你可以得到一份全套饭菜——也就是肉和三种蔬菜——只要25美分。
I remember distinctly feeding little snotty-nosed white kids. My father and mother just did this out of the goodness of their heart. I guess there must have been 10 white families within 50 feet of us. And I remember feeding them. I remember my parents feeding little black kids. I remember when the times got so hard, the sheriff pawned a radio to my father for $10. This was a white sheriff, a white official, who had to come to a black man to get $10. The reason he needed the $10, he had some people out of town. He wanted to bring them there to eat some chicken.
我清楚地记得喂那些流着鼻涕的白人小孩。我的父母只是出于好心才这么做的。我想在我们周围50英尺内一定有10个白人家庭。我记得喂他们。我记得我的父母喂那些黑人小孩。我记得时局非常艰难的时候，警长把收音机抵押给我父亲换了10美元。这是一个白人警长，一个白人官员，不得不来找一个黑人拿10美元。他需要这10美元的原因是，他带了一些外地人来。他想带他们去吃鸡肉。
Do you think a Depression of that intensity could come again?
你认为那种强度的萧条还会再发生吗？
I think it could come again. But I think it would behoove the federal government not to let it come. Because you're dealing with a different breed of cattle now. See, now, if they really want anarchy, let a depression come now. My 16-year-old son is not the person I was when I was 16. He's an adult at 16. He's working in a department store and going to school, too. So he has manly responsibilities. And he doesn't want any [BLEEP]. These kids now do not want it. When I was 16, I wasn't afraid to die. But the key at 16 now is not afraid to kill.
我认为它可能再次发生。但我认为联邦政府有义务不让它发生。因为你现在面对的是一种不同种类的牛。你看，现在，如果他们真的想要无政府状态，那就让萧条发生吧。我16岁的儿子不是我16岁时那样。他在16岁时就是个成年人了。他在百货商店工作，也去上学。所以他有男人的责任。他不想要任何[脏话]。现在的孩子不想要这些。我16岁时，我不怕死。但现在16岁的关键是，不怕杀人。
From 1935 to 1939, I worked at El Morocco. And I invented a thing which has become a pain in the neck to most people. I took photographs of the fashionable people and sent them to the papers. These were the women who dressed the best. These were the women who had the most beautiful of all jewels. These were the dream people that we all looked up to and hoped that we, or our friends, could sometimes know and be like.
从1935年到1939年，我在El Morocco工作。我发明了一样东西，这东西成了大多数人的眼中钉。我给时髦的人拍照，然后把照片发给报社。这些是穿着最好的女性。这些是拥有最华丽珠宝的女性。这些是我们所有人仰望并希望我们，或者我们的朋友，有时能认识并变得像她们一样的梦想人物。
Do you ever talk about what happened outside? There were breadlines. There were various other things occurring, not too nice, you know.
你有没有谈论过外面发生了什么？有面包排队。还有各种其他事情发生，不太美好，你知道的。
As I remember, I don't think they ever mentioned them. Never, socially. Because-- I've always had a theory. When you're out with friends, out socially, everything must be charming. And you don't allow the ugly. We don't even discuss the Negro question.
据我记忆，我不认为他们提过。从来没有，在社交场合。因为——我一直有个理论。当你和朋友在一起，在社交场合，一切都必须是迷人的。你不能允许丑陋。我们甚至不讨论黑人问题。
What was happening around the city? Do you remember the people talk of breadlines, or Hoovervilles, or apple sellers?
城里发生了什么？你还记得人们谈论面包排队、胡佛村或卖苹果的人吗？
No, there were none of those.
不，没有那些。
No.
不。
Not in New York. Never, never. There were a few beggars.
在纽约没有。从来没有。只有几个乞丐。
New deal.
新政。
New deal? Well, that was an invention of Franklin Roosevelt's that meant absolutely nothing except higher taxation. And that he did.
新政？嗯，那是富兰克林·罗斯福的一项发明，除了更高的税收外，什么意义都没有。而他确实那样做了。
The '30s society, a last image.
30年代的社会，最后的影像。
It was a glamorous, glittering moment.
那是一个迷人、闪耀的时刻。
Well, I lived off friends. I had a very good friend who cashed in all his Bonus Bonds to pay his rent. And he had an extra bed, so he let me sleep there. I finally went on relief, which was an experience I wouldn't want anybody else ever to go through in New York City. A single man going on relief, at that particular time, was just-- well, it comes as close to crucifixion as you can do it, without the actual mechanical details.
嗯，我靠朋友生活。我有个非常好的朋友把所有奖金债券兑现来支付房租。他有一张多余的床，所以他让我睡在那里。我最终去申请救济，那是在纽约市我不想让任何人再经历一次的经历。一个单身男子在那个特定时间去申请救济，简直就是——嗯，这几乎等同于被钉死在十字架上，除了没有实际的机械细节。
Well, it was '35 or '36, in that area. It was after I lost my job with the publishing house. And I needed whatever money I could get anywhere. The interview was, to me, utterly ridiculous and mortifying. But it was questions like, well, what have you been living on? Well, I borrowed some money. Who'd you borrow it from? Friends. Who are your friends? Where have you been living? I've been living with friends.
嗯，那是35年或36年左右。那是在我失去出版社工作之后。我需要任何我能得到的钱。对我来说，那个采访简直荒谬且令人羞辱。但是问题就像，嗯，你一直靠什么生活？嗯，我借了一些钱。你从谁那儿借的？朋友。你的朋友是谁？你一直住在哪儿？我一直和朋友住在一起。
Well, I wish I could recall the whole thing. This went on for a half an hour or something. I finally turned to the young man who was interviewing me and said, I've been talking about friends. Do you happen to know what a friend is? And a little after that, I got my-- at least the interview was over. I did get certified some time later. I've been trying to remember how much they paid. It seems to me it was $9 a month.
嗯，希望我能记得整个过程。这持续了大约半小时。我终于转向那个采访我的年轻人说，我一直在谈论朋友。你碰巧知道什么是朋友吗？在那之后不久，我得到了我的——至少采访结束了。我确实在一段时间后得到了认证。我一直在努力回忆他们付了多少钱。在我看来，是每月9美元。
$9 a month. But the thing you remember is this humiliating experience.
每月9美元。但你记住的是这种羞辱性的经历。
That's right. Well, I suppose there's some reason in the back of it. I'm a single man who was white. Why didn't I have a family? And I had sent my family West to Ohio, where they could live simply.
没错。嗯，我想这背后是有原因的。我是个单身白人男子。我为什么没有家庭？我已经把家人送到西部的俄亥俄州了，他们可以在那里简单地生活。
But they asked, then, all these personal questions.
但他们当时问了所有这些个人问题。
It was-- well, I don't know. I came away feeling like I hadn't any business even living any longer. I was imposing on somebody's great society, or something like that.
那真是——嗯，我不知道。我离开时感觉好像我再也没理由活下去了。我好像在强加于某人的伟大社会，或者类似的东西。
And now we come to the voice of Elsa Ponselle, who recalls her young womanhood as a schoolteacher during the Depression.
现在我们来到艾尔莎·庞塞尔的声音，她回忆起她在大萧条时期作为一名女教师的年轻时代。
My nephew, not so long ago, said to me-- in regards to the Negro problem-- ah, if they want a job, they can get it. I said, if you ever say that again, I don't care if you are damn near 40 years old, I'll slap you. I said, your father couldn't get a job during the Depression. And he wanted one. Well, of course he's forgotten. I mean, he never even knew. But I mean, I felt all that old rage coming back. I mean, like, when I was in my 20s. And somebody said, oh, if they want a job. If they really want to work, they can get it.
我的侄子，不久前对我说——关于黑人问题——啊，如果他们想要一份工作，他们就能得到。我说，如果你再敢说一次，我不管你是不是快40岁了，我会给你一耳光。我说，你父亲在大萧条时期找不到工作。而他想要一份。好吧，当然他忘记了。我是说，他甚至根本不知道。但我确实感觉到那种旧日的愤怒又回来了。我是说，就像我在20多岁时那样。有人说，哦，如果他们想要工作。如果他们真的想工作，他们就能得到。
And so the Depression was a way of life to me. I mean, consider that from the time I was 20 to the time I was 30, I lived in a Depression-oriented universe. And I thought, unconsciously, that that was the way it was going to be forever and ever and ever, that people would have trouble getting jobs, that they would be living in fear of losing their jobs. You know, that fear of losing their jobs.
所以大萧条对我来说是一种生活方式。我是说，考虑到从我20岁到30岁，我生活在一个以萧条为导向的宇宙里。我潜意识里以为这就是永远，这就是那样，人们会很难找到工作，他们会生活在失去工作的恐惧中。你知道，那种失去工作的恐惧。
During the Depression, when you were poor, you weren't looking around and seeing, here is a society in which everybody has something except me. And by God, I'm going to get some. I mean, I can't blame people for feeling-- they read the papers and they watch television and everybody is so rich and has everything-- why not me?
在大萧条期间，当你贫穷时，你不会环顾四周看到，这是一个每个人都拥有东西而我没有的社会。老天，我要得到一些。我是说，我不能责怪人们有这种感觉——他们读报纸看电视，每个人都那么富有，拥有一切——为什么我不能呢？
You see, that was the difference in the Depression. It wasn't only not me, but it was not you, and it was not my friends, and everybody else. And the rich had the instinct of self-preservation. They didn't throw the fact that they had money around, if you'll remember. We heard about how they didn't have the fancy debutante parties, because after all, it was not the thing to do.
你看，这就是大萧条的区别。不仅不是我，而且不是你，也不是我的朋友，和其他所有人。富人有自我保护的本能。如果你还记得的话，他们不会炫耀自己有钱的事实。我们听说过他们如何不举行华丽的名媛舞会，因为毕竟，那不是该做的事。
They're a bit more discreet about it.
他们在这方面稍微谨慎一点。
Indeed. They were so God damn scared they'd have a revolution. They damn near did, too, didn't they?
确实。他们吓坏了，怕发生革命。他们差点就发生了，不是吗？
You felt that? You felt they were scared?
你感觉到了吗？你感觉到他们害怕了吗？
Oh, were they scared! What's more scary than $1 million? Which you can send over to the Swiss banks, and they're still sending it over to the Swiss banks.
哦，他们多害怕啊！有什么比100万美元更可怕的？你可以把它送到瑞士银行，而他们仍然在把它送到瑞士银行。
Well, this leads to several questions. Then, the question of status did not make itself felt, then? Because your neighbor, everybody you knew was like you.
嗯，这引出了几个问题。那么，地位的问题当时并没有显现出来？因为你的邻居，你认识的每一个人都和你一样。
That's right. Your neighbor was losing his house. Somebody else was having their furniture taken away. And everybody was in the same boat. And in fact, I think people who were not in that boat were a little apologetic because they weren't suffering. And then, of course, the war came. And the Depression was cured by a war, which was one hell of a note. And all these kids that I had had, who were growing up, disappeared. And it was very, very quiet. The young were gone. And some of them came back, and some of them didn't.
没错。你的邻居在失去房子。其他人正在被没收家具。每个人都在同一条船上。事实上，我认为不在那条船上的人有点道歉，因为他们没有受苦。然后，当然，战争来了。大萧条被一场战争治愈了，这可真是个天大的笑话。我所教的那些正在长大的孩子们，都消失了。非常，非常安静。年轻人走了。有些人回来了，有些人没有。
In Jefferson county, about 4/5 of the people were on relief. And there was no government relief. So this meant that they had just this $2.50 a week that the Red Cross provided them, and what they could beg, borrow, or steal. But the thing that also struck me as being so terrible was that, just the way my mother and father had this terrible feeling of shame and guilt, and there was that failure that lost all their property, these people had the same feeling of shame and guilt when they lost their jobs.
在杰斐逊县，大约4/5的人靠救济生活。那时没有政府救济。所以这意味着他们只有红十字会提供的每周2.50美元，以及他们能乞讨、借用或偷窃的东西。但最让我感到可怕的是，就像我父母那种可怕的羞耻和内疚感一样，那种失去所有财产的失败感，这些人失去工作时也有同样的羞耻和内疚感。
And they didn't blame the Republic Steel Company or the United States Steel. They didn't blame the capitalist system. They just blamed themselves. And they thought-- well, they would say in the most apologetic way, well, you know if we hadn't bought that radio, if we hadn't bought that old secondhand car, if we'd saved our money and-- you know, they really blamed themselves. And it was this terrible feeling they had of shame that they were on relief.
他们没有责怪共和国钢铁公司或美国钢铁公司。他们没有责怪资本主义制度。他们只是责怪自己。他们会想——嗯，他们会用最抱歉的方式说，好吧，你知道如果我们没买那个收音机，如果我们没买那辆旧二手车，如果我们存了钱——你知道，他们真的责怪自己。他们对于靠救济生活有一种可怕的羞耻感。
We just drifted back and forth. He was discontented everywhere. And then, we went back to Oklahoma the last time in January of 1929. And I had three children born there.
我们只是来回漂泊。他在哪里都不满足。然后，我们在1929年1月最后一次回到俄克拉荷马州。我在那里生了三个孩子。
You remember situations of how they got the families around there, too?
你还记得他们如何带着家庭四处奔波的情况吗？
Oh, yes. I remember several families there that lost their homes and everything they had-- their bank account and everything they had-- and had to leave there in covered wagons, for instance.
哦，是的。我记得那里有好几个家庭失去了家园和拥有的一切——他们的银行账户和所有东西——不得不坐着篷车离开那里，例如。
Covered wagons?
篷车？
Covered wagons, absolutely they went out of there in covered wagons, in the '30s.
篷车，绝对是，他们在30年代坐着篷车离开那里。
Do you remember people taking part in demonstrations of any sort?
你还记得人们参加任何形式的示威活动吗？
My husband went to Washington.
我丈夫去了华盛顿。
Your husband did?
你丈夫去了？
Well, indeed he did. He marched with that group that went to Washington. Let's see, what year was that, Peggy?
嗯，确实去了。他参加了那次去华盛顿的队伍。让我想想，那是哪一年，佩吉？
The Bonus Marchers?
奖金游行者？
Oh, yes, sir.
哦，是的，先生。
Oh, your husband was a Bonus Marcher?
哦，你丈夫是奖金游行者？
Oh, yes, sir. He was a hellraiser. You know he was in World War I. he was a machine gunner in World War I. And he felt like that the men that fought in the war should have their bonus, especially at a time like it was then-- and then, without employment and with families to support.
哦，是的，先生。他是个造反派。你知道他在第一次世界大战中服役。他是第一次世界大战中的机枪手。他觉得参加战争的人应该得到他们的奖金，特别是在当时那种时候——而且那时没有工作，还有家庭要养。
Mama, don't you remember when Daddy used to say, the God damn Germans gassed me. And I come home, and my own God damn government gassed me.
妈妈，你不记得爸爸过去常说，“该死的德国人用毒气害我。我回家后，我自己的政府用毒气害我。”
Yes, he said that, too.
是的，他也说过。
Oh--
哦——
He was a machine gunner. And the God damn Germans gassed him in Germany. And he came home, and his own government stooges gassed him and run him off the country up there with water hose, half-drowned him. He was very bitter. Because he was an intelligent man. And he couldn't see why, as wealthy a country as this is-- that there was any sense in so many people practically starving to death, and living in such dire poverty, when so much of it was-- wheat and everything else-- was being poured in the ocean. And many, many things that were happening, that was taking food out of people's mouths and homes. He was very bitter.
他是机枪手。该死的德国人在德国用毒气害了他。他回到家，他政府里的走狗用毒气害了他，并用水管把他从那个国家赶了出去，差点淹死他。他非常痛苦。因为他是一个聪明人。他无法理解，为什么像这个国家这样富裕的国家——让那么多人几乎饿死，生活在如此极端的贫困中，是毫无意义的，而小麦和其他一切——都被倒进了大海。还有很多很多正在发生的事情，那是从人们的嘴里和家里夺走食物。他非常痛苦。
Peggy, when were you aware of the Depression?
佩吉，你是什么时候意识到大萧条的？
I believe, when I first started noticing the difference was when we'd come home from school in the evening, my mother'd send us to the soup line. And we were never allowed to cuss. But after we'd been going to the soup line for about a month, we'd go down there, and if you happened to be one of the first ones in line, you didn't get anything but water that was on top. So we'd ask the guy that was ladling out the soup into the buckets-- everybody had to bring their own bucket to get the soup. And he'd dip the greasy, watery stuff off the top. And so we'd ask him to please dip down so we could get some meat and potatoes from the bottom of the kettle. And he wouldn't do it. So then we learned a cuss, and we'd say dip down, God damn it!
我相信，我第一次注意到区别的时候，是我们傍晚放学回家，我妈妈会让我们去排队领汤。我们从不允许骂人。但在排队领汤大约一个月后，我们去那里，如果你碰巧是队伍里第一个，你得到的除了漂在上面的水，什么也没有。所以我们会问那个把汤舀进桶里的人——每个人都必须自带桶去领汤。他会舀掉上面的油腻、水汪汪的东西。所以我们求他舀深一点，这样我们就能从锅底得到一些肉和土豆。但他不肯。所以我们学会了一句脏话，我们会说“舀深一点，该死的！”
And then we'd go across the street. And one place had bread, large loaves of bread. And then, down the road, just a little piece, was a big shed. And they gave milk. And my sister and me would take two buckets each. And we'd bring one back full of soup, and one back full of milk, and two loaves of bread each. And that's what we lived on for the longest time.
然后我们穿过街道。一个地方有面包，大块的面包。然后，顺着路走一小段，是一个大棚子。他们给牛奶。我和我姐姐每人带两个桶。我们带回一桶满满的汤，一桶满满的牛奶，还有每人两条面包。这就是我们很长一段时间赖以生存的东西。
And I can remember-- one time, we didn't have anything to eat. And I don't know if this was before the soup line. But I remember the only thing in the house to eat was mustard. And my sister and me put so much mustard on biscuits that we got sick. And we can't stand mustard right today.
而且我记得——有一次，我们没有任何吃的。我不知道这是否在排队领汤之前。但我记得家里唯一能吃的就是芥末。我和我姐姐在饼干上涂了太多芥末，结果我们病了。直到今天我们都受不了芥末。
You didn't feel at that time-- you and your little friends, your young friends-- a sense of shame?
那时候你和你的小玩伴们，没有感到一种羞耻感吗？
No. I remember it was fun. It was fun going to the soup line, because we all went down the road, and we laughed, and we played. The only thing that we felt was we were hungry, and we were going to get food. And nobody made us feel ashamed. There just wasn't any of that.
没有。我记得那很有趣。去排队领汤很有趣，因为我们都沿着路走，我们笑，我们玩。我们唯一的感觉是饿，我们要去得到食物。没人让我们感到羞耻。根本没有那种事。
Back then, I'm not sure how the rich felt. I think the rich were as contemptuous of the poor then as they are now. But at least among the people that I knew and came in contact with, we all had a sense of understanding that it wasn't our fault, that it was something that had happened to the machinery. And in fact, most people blamed Hoover. I mean, they'd cuss him up one side and down the other-- it was all his fault. Well, I'm not saying he's blameless, but I'm not saying either that it was all his fault. Because our system doesn't run just by one man, and it doesn't fall just by one man either.
那时，我不确定富人是什么感觉。我认为那时候的富人对穷人的蔑视和现在一样。但至少在我认识和接触的人中间，我们都有种理解，这不是我们的错，这是机器发生了某些故障。事实上，大多数人责怪胡佛。我是说，他们会从头到尾诅咒他——那全是他的错。好吧，我不是说他没有过错，但我也不是说那全是他的错。因为我们的系统不是由一个人运行的，也不是由一个人就垮掉的。
How much schooling do you have?
你上过多少学？
Sixth grade.
小学六年级。
You had sixth grade, and then you went to work?
你读了六年级，然后就去工作了？
Yeah.
是的。
Then what did you do after sixth grade? You got married at 15.
六年级以后你做了什么？你在15岁就结婚了。
Yes. Well, my husband and me start traveling around. That was just kind of our background. And we just kind of continued it. We went down in the valley of Texas, where it's very beautiful. We were migrant workers down there. We picked oranges and grapefruits and lemons and limes in the Rio Grande Valley. It's really a good life if you're poor and you manage to move around.
是的。好吧，我和我丈夫开始到处旅行。那是我们的背景。我们就这样继续下去了。我们去了德克萨斯州的河谷，那里非常美丽。我们在那里当流动工人。我们在里奥格兰德河谷采摘橙子、葡萄柚、柠檬和酸橙。如果你很穷并且设法四处移动，那确实是一种不错的生活。
Well, how did you and your husband get around? What means of transportation?
嗯，你和你丈夫是怎么四处走动的？什么交通工具？
We hitchhiked. I was pregnant when we first started hitchhiking. And people were really very nice to us. Sometimes they would feed us, and then sometimes we would-- I remember, the one time we slept in a haystack. And the lady of the house came out and found us. And she says, well, this is really very bad for you, because you're going to have a baby. And she says, you need a lot of milk. So she took us up to the house. And she had a lot of rugs hanging on the clothesline. She was doing her house cleaning. And we told her we'd beat the rugs for her giving us the food. And she said, no, she didn't expect that, that she just wanted to feed us. And we said, no, that we couldn't take it unless we worked for it. So she let us beat her rugs. And I think she had a million rugs. And we cleaned them. And then we went in. And she had a beautiful table, just all full of all kind of food and milk. And then when we left, she filled a gallon bucket full of milk. And we took it with us.
我们搭便车。我们刚开始搭便车时我怀孕了。人们真的对我们很好。有时他们会给我们饭吃，有时我们——我记得，有一次我们睡在干草堆里。房子的女主人出来发现了我们。她说，嗯，这真的对你们很不好，因为你们要生孩子了。她说，你们需要大量的牛奶。所以她带我们去了房子。她晾衣绳上挂着很多地毯。她正在做大扫除。我们告诉她，只要给我们食物，我们就帮她拍打地毯。她说，不，她没指望那个，她只是想给我们饭吃。我们说，不，除非我们工作，否则我们不能接受。所以她让我们拍打她的地毯。我想她有一百万块地毯。我们清理了它们。然后我们进去了。她有一张漂亮的桌子，上面摆满了各种各样的食物和牛奶。当我们离开时，她装了一加仑桶的牛奶。我们随身带着它。
And you don't find that now. I think maybe if you did that now, you'd get arrested. I think somebody'd call the police. I think maybe the atmosphere since the end of the second war, because all kind of propaganda has been going on. It just seems like the minute the war ended, the propaganda started-- and making people hate each other, not just hate Russians and Chinese and Germans. It was to make us hate each other, I think. I know one thing that people have to get over-- is they have to quit hating black people. That's the first thing. Because you always see yourself as something you're not. You see yourself as better than other human beings. As long as you can hate black people, and as long as you can say, I'm better than they are, then there's somebody below you you can kick.
你现在找不到那种事了。我想如果你现在那样做，你会被逮捕。我想有人会报警。我想也许自从二战结束以来，因为各种宣传一直在进行，气氛就变了。好像战争一结束，宣传就开始了——让人互相憎恨，不仅是恨俄罗斯人、中国人、德国人。我认为那是让我们互相憎恨。我知道人们必须克服的一件事——是他们必须停止憎恨黑人。那是第一件事。因为你总是把你看作你不是的东西。你把自己看作比其他人类更好。只要你能憎恨黑人，只要你能说，我比他们好，那么你下面就有人可以踢。
But once you get over that, you see and you begin to understand that you're not any better off than they are. In fact, you're worse off because you're believing a lie. And in that way, they're smarter than we are, because we couldn't see that. And it was right in front of us. We'd be out in a cotton field chopping cotton. And we'd see the black people over in the next field. But never once did it occur to me that we had anything in common. Because they were black and I was white. And that made it different.
但一旦你克服了这一点，你就会明白你并不比他们好。事实上，你更糟糕，因为你在相信一个谎言。从这个意义上说，他们比我们聪明，因为我们看不到这一点。它就在我们面前。我们在棉田里锄棉花。我们会看到黑人在隔壁田里。但我从来没想过我们有什么共同点。因为他们是黑人，我是白人。那使得一切变得不同。
You had that feeling of being superior then?
你那时候有那种优越感吗？
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
Your husband did, too?
你丈夫也有吗？
Yes.
是的。
Down in Texas, these are Mexican people?
在德克萨斯，那些是墨西哥人吗？
Oh, yes. But I didn't feel any identification with them either. The men and the women, they were just spics. And they should be sent back to Mexico, because they shouldn't be over here in the first place. That was the way I felt at that time. Now, since then, I found out that that very state, we took away from them in the first place. So I feel pretty bad about that.
哦，是的。但我也没有对他们产生任何认同感。男男女女，他们只是“spic”（对西班牙裔的蔑称）。他们应该被送回墨西哥，因为他们本来就不该来这里。我当时就是这么想的。从那以后，我发现那个州，我们本来就是从他们手里夺过来的。所以对此我感到很糟糕。
And then, when did this other insight come to you? Any idea when? That feeling you have now.
那么，这种洞察力是什么时候产生的？知道是什么时候吗？你现在拥有的那种感觉。
I think maybe it started in Montgomery, because we were living there when the bus boycott started. They hired a bunch of real tough guys to make the Negroes ride the buses. And I saw them pick those women up and throw them on the bus. And a couple of times, I was on the bus myself. And they'd wait until the bus stopped at the corner, and they'd throw those women on the bus. And the women'd just stand there. They wouldn't move. And then when the bus got to the next corner, they'd get off and they'd walk. They would not stay on that bus.
我想也许是从蒙哥马利开始的，因为公车抵制运动开始时我们住在那里。他们雇了一群非常强硬的家伙逼迫黑人坐公车。我看到他们抓住那些妇女，把她们扔上公车。有几次，我自己也在公车上。他们会等公车在拐角处停下，然后把那些妇女扔上公车。那些妇女只是站在那里。她们不动。然后当公车到达下一个拐角时，她们就下车步行。她们不会留在公车上。
And then my husband got in jail in Montgomery. And I went down to the jail one day to see him. And who'd they have out there, but Reverend Martin Luther King down on the sidewalk, beating him up, about 10 guys. And I felt this was wrong. I don't know why I felt it was wrong. It just bothered me. He was just a nigger to me at that point. But it really bothered me to see a gang beating up on him.
然后我丈夫在蒙哥马利进了监狱。有一天我去了监狱看他。你在那儿看到了谁，但马丁·路德·金牧师在人行道上，大约10个人在打他。我觉得这是错的。我不知道为什么我觉得它是错的。它只是困扰着我。那时他对我来说只是个“黑鬼”。但看到一群人围殴他真的困扰着我。
And one other thing that I know really touched me was the store where I always went to buy my groceries. It was a big supermarket. And they had a little, tiny Negro woman. She didn't look like she weighed 100 pounds. And they had her putting up stock. And this great big white guy came in there and filled the shopping cart full of groceries. And then when he checked them out, she was standing there, dusting the shelves. And he says, come here and take these groceries out to my car.
还有一件事我真的感触很深，就是我总是去买杂货的商店。那是一家大超市。他们有一个非常娇小的黑人妇女。她看起来不到100磅。他们让她去上架。那个高大的白人男人进来了，装满了购物车的杂货。然后当他结账时，她站在那里，给货架除尘。他说，过来，把这些杂货拿到我的车上去。
And so she came up there, and she started pushing the cart out the door. And he went out ahead of her. And even though she was taking his groceries-- he was a great big able-bodied man-- he let the door slam on her. He wouldn't even hold the door open for her. So I went and I held the door open. And even when it was happening, I couldn't hardly believe it was happening. And then I said to him something about great big he-men. I don't remember exactly what I said, but it was really nasty, because I felt bad because he did that.
于是她走过来，开始把购物车推向门口。他走在她前面。即使她是在帮他拿杂货——他是一个高大、身体健全的男人——他还是让门撞在了她身上。他甚至不愿为她扶住门。所以我过去帮她扶住了门。即使在发生的时候，我也几乎不敢相信它正在发生。然后我跟他说了一些关于高大男人之类的话。我不记得具体说了什么，但真的很刻薄，因为他那样做让我感到很难受。
It's really hard to talk about at a time like that, because it seems like a different person. When I remember those times, it's like looking into a world where another person is doing those things. And it's just so hard to relate them to myself.
在那种时候谈论这件事真的很困难，因为它感觉就像另一个人。当我回忆那些时光时，就像看着一个世界，另一个人在做那些事。很难把它们和自己联系起来。
This may sound impossible, but do you know, if there's one thing that started me thinking, it was President Roosevelt's cuff links. I read in the paper about how many pairs of cuff links he had, and it told that some of them were rubies, and all precious stones. These were his cuff links.
这听起来可能是不可能的，但你知道吗，如果有一件事让我开始思考，那就是罗斯福总统的袖扣。我在报纸上读到他有多少副袖扣，上面说其中一些是红宝石，还有所有珍贵的宝石。这是他的袖扣。
And I just wondered, I'll never forget. I was sitting on an old tire out in the front yard. And we were hungry. And I was wondering why it was that one man could have all those cuff links when we couldn't even have enough to eat, when we lived on gravy and biscuits. And I think, maybe, that was my first thought of wondering why. That's the first thing I remember ever wondering why.
我只是想知道，我永远不会忘记。我当时坐在前院的一个旧轮胎上。我们饿了。我很好奇为什么一个人能拥有所有那些袖扣，而我们甚至连饭都吃不饱，当我们只靠肉汁和饼干生活时。我想，也许，那是我第一次怀疑为什么。那是我记得第一次思考为什么。
But one thing I did want to say about when my father finally got his bonus-- he bought a secondhand car for us to come back to Kentucky in. And my dad said to us kids, all of you get in the car. I want to take you and show you something. And on the way over there, he talked about how rough life had been for us. And he said, if you think it's been rough for us, he said, I want you to see people that really had it rough.
但我确实想说一件事，当父亲最终拿到他的奖金时——他买了一辆二手车让我们回肯塔基州。爸爸对我们孩子说，你们都上车。我想带你们去看看东西。在路上，他谈到我们的生活有多艰难。他说，如果你们认为我们的生活艰难，他说，我希望你们看看那些真正生活艰难的人。
This was in Oklahoma City, and he took us to one of the Hoovervilles. And that was the most incredible thing. Here were all these people living in old, rusted-out car bodies. I mean, that was their home. There were people living in shacks made out of orange crates. One family with a whole lot of kids were living in a piano box. And here, this wasn't just a little section. This was an area maybe 10 miles wide and 10 miles long. People living in whatever they could jam together.
那是在俄克拉荷马城，他带我们去了胡佛村之一。那真是不可思议。这里所有这些人住在生锈的旧车壳里。我是说，那是他们的家。有人住在橘子箱做的棚子里。一个有许多孩子的家庭住在一个钢琴盒里。而且这不仅仅是一个小区域。这是一个可能有10英里宽、10英里长的区域。人们住在他们能挤在一起的任何地方。
And when I read Grapes of Wrath , that was like re-living my life, particularly the part in there about where they lived in this government camp. Because when we were picking fruit in Texas, we lived in a government place like that, a government-owned place, in Robstown, Texas. And they came around and they helped the women make mattresses. See, we didn't have anything. And they helped us make-- they showed us how to sew and make dresses. And every Saturday night, we'd have a dance. And when I was reading Grapes of Wrath , this was just like my life.
当我读《愤怒的葡萄》时，那就像重温我的生活，特别是书里关于他们住在政府营地的那部分。因为我们在德克萨斯采摘水果时，我们就住在德克萨斯州罗布斯敦那样的一个政府地方，一个政府拥有的地方。他们过来帮助妇女制作床垫。你看，我们什么都没有。他们帮我们制作——他们教我们如何缝纫和制作连衣裙。每个星期六晚上，我们都会举行舞会。当我读《愤怒的葡萄》时，这简直就像我的生活。
And I never was so proud of poor people before as I was after I read that book. And just reading that book has made me a better person. I think that's the worst thing that our system does to people, is to take away their pride. And it prevents them from being a human being. And they're wondering, why the Harlem, and why the Detroit? And they're talking about troops and law and order. And you'll get law and order in this country when people are allowed to be decent human beings, and be able to walk in dignity.
我从来没有像读完那本书之后那样为穷人感到自豪。仅仅是读那本书就让我成为了一个更好的人。我认为这是我们的系统对人们做的最坏的事，就是夺走他们的尊严。这阻碍了他们成为一个人。他们还在问，为什么要哈林，为什么要底特律？他们还在谈论军队和法律与秩序。在这个国家，只有当人们被允许成为体面的人，并且能够有尊严地行走时，你才能得到法律与秩序。
That was A Gathering of Survivors : Voices of the Great American Depression . The program was produced by Studs Terkel, with Jim Unrath and Lois Baum, of radio station WFMT Chicago.
那是《幸存者聚会：美国大萧条的声音》。该节目由斯塔兹·特克尔、吉姆·昂拉斯和芝加哥WFMT广播电台的洛伊斯·鲍姆制作。
Coming up, What a Difference an Election Day Makes. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues. It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today, we have stories of insiders and outsiders, haves and have nots. And of course, on Tuesday of this past week, an outsider became the biggest inside there is, President of the United States.
接下来，选举日带来了什么改变。稍后就回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，并为你带来关于那个主题的各种故事。今天，我们有关于圈内人和圈外人、富有者和贫困者的故事。当然，在过去这一周的周二，一个圈外人成为了最大的圈内人，即美国总统。
Which brings us to Act Two. Listening this last week to those old recordings that Studs Terkel made, where people were talking about their view of this country, and of their fellow Americans, and how those views evolved over the decades, I wondered what this election would do, how much it would close the divide between people, particularly between blacks and whites. And I was especially curious about blacks who had seen this country at its worst, who lived through segregation. And looking for somebody to talk to about that here on the radio, I eventually got on the phone with Reverend Donald Sharp, who leads a Baptist Church on Chicago's South Side, Faith Tabernacle. And when I called him and asked him what his thoughts were this week, he was already on the same page that I was.
这把我们带到了第二幕。过去这一周听着斯塔兹·特克尔制作的那些旧录音，人们谈论他们对这个国家的看法，以及对他们的美国同胞的看法，以及这些看法在几十年间是如何演变的，我想知道这次选举会带来什么，它能在多大程度上缩小人们之间的鸿沟，特别是黑人和白人之间的鸿沟。我特别好奇那些见证过这个国家最糟糕时期、经历过种族隔离的黑人们的想法。为了在电台找到可以交流的对象，我最终和唐纳德·夏普牧师通了电话，他在芝加哥南区领导着一家浸信会教堂，信心会幕。当我打电话问他这周有什么想法时，他已经和我想到一块儿去了。
When I asked him about Tuesday, he started immediately talking about things that happened to him back in the '50s, how he's found himself thinking about those things this week, like being taken as a teenager to see the body of Emmett Till, who was a Chicago kid like him, around his age, who was killed while visiting relatives in Mississippi. Donald Sharp also had relatives in Mississippi.
当我问他关于周二的事时，他立刻开始谈论他在50年代经历过的事情，以及这周他是如何发现自己一直在想那些事情的，比如作为一个青少年被带去看埃米特·蒂尔的尸体，那是个像他一样的芝加哥孩子，年纪和他差不多，在密西西比州探亲时被杀害了。唐纳德·夏普在密西西比州也有亲戚。
He told me all kinds of ugly things that happened to him when he was drafted in 1960 and sent to Oklahoma. How he wasn't served food at a restaurant on the way down, even though he was in uniform. How in Oklahoma, black and white soldiers were sent to separate, but very unequal, USO dances, a nice one for the white soldiers, a USO club that was kind of a dump for the black soldiers. He saw things in Oklahoma he'd never seen in Chicago. And that made him angry.
他告诉我他在1960年应征入伍并被派往俄克拉荷马州时发生的所有各种丑陋的事情。即便他穿着制服，在去那里的餐馆时却没有得到食物。在俄克拉荷马州，黑人士兵和白人士兵被送到分开但非常不平等的USO舞会，白人士兵有一个漂亮的舞会，而USO俱乐部对黑人士兵来说简直就是个垃圾场。他在俄克拉荷马州看到了一些他在芝加哥从未见过的事情。这让他很愤怒。
That was-- believe me, believe me, believe me, I wanted to go AWOL. I felt like, was it really worth it all? Was this country really worth dying for? I felt as though that I was just a commodity to be used by this country. And my worth to this country has not increased no more than my great-grandfather, who was a slave down in Mississippi. Only thing, I've been permitted to have a little bit more amenities. So all this is a part of who I am, not being able to eat in the restaurant, or going to a segregated dance.
那是——相信我，相信我，相信我，我当时想开小差。我心想，这真的值得吗？这个国家真的值得为它献身吗？我感觉我就像是这个国家可以随便使用的商品。我对这个国家的价值并不比我在密西西比州当奴隶的曾祖父多。唯一的事情是，我被允许拥有一点点更多的便利设施。所以所有这些都是我的一部分，不能在餐馆吃饭，或者去参加种族隔离的舞会。
And so this week, when Barack Obama became president, does it make you adjust how you see this country?
所以这周，当巴拉克·奥巴马成为总统时，这让你调整你看待这个国家的方式了吗？
I see it a little bit different, but my guard is not totally down. I'm being facetious when I say this-- I'm not going to be around, out singing "We Have Overcome." I feel good for him and his family. And I'm hoping-- I'm cautiously optimistic. I'm happy but, you know--
我看法稍微有点不同，但我的防备并没有完全放下。我这么说是开玩笑的——我不会去唱“我们终将胜利”。我为他和他的家人感到高兴。我希望——我谨慎地感到乐观。我很高兴，但是，你知道——
Wait, and what's the but?
等等，“但是”是什么？
That's the question. The but is my suspicion. See, I still haven't been able to shed my suspicious nature of systemic and institutional racism. Part of the problem is being black, you're living in these two different worlds, one in which you know you're a permanent citizen of, and the other, you are granted visas, shall I say. You go back and forth between these worlds. And I use the term not in a strict medical sense, but you become schizophrenic in your behavior. You're one way over here and you're another way over there.
这就是问题所在。这个“但是”就是我的怀疑。你看，我还没能摆脱我对系统性和制度性种族主义的怀疑本性。部分问题在于作为黑人，你生活在这两个不同的世界里，一个你知道你是永久公民的世界，另一个，你被授予了签证，我应该这么说。你在这些世界之间来回穿梭。我使用这个词并不是在严格的医学意义上，但你的行为会变得精神分裂。你在这一边是一种方式，在那一边又是另一种方式。
And also, at the same time, sometimes you feel like, oh, yeah, things are fine. I'm fine. And other times, you realize, like, oh, no, maybe I'm not fine.
而且，与此同时，有时候你感觉，哦，是的，一切都很好。我很好。而在另一些时候，你意识到，哦，不，也许我并不好。
Exactly.
完全正确。
So that feeling of being split, that doesn't end because of one election day.
所以那种被分裂的感觉，不会因为一个选举日就结束。
No. Goodness gracious, no. Not by any stretch to the imagination. And so that's my skepticism. Now, I'm quite certain that my grandchildren see it a little bit different. And I hope they would.
不。老天，不会的。无论如何都不会。这就是我的怀疑。现在，我很确定我的孙子们看法稍微不同。我希望他们会这样。
Now, how do your grandchildren see it?
那么，你的孙子们是怎么看的？
They're excited. They're geeked. They're happy. They feel like, boy, it's a new day. But again, they've not experienced some of the things I've experienced. I remember telling my kids, I said, I remember when I would go downtown and we'd change the train in Memphis, I would see two water fountains. There was a sign that said, one white, one colored. And they'd start laughing. They'd say, you really saw that? That really happened? Yes, that really happened.
他们很兴奋。他们很狂热。他们很高兴。他们觉得，天哪，这是新的一天。但再一次，他们没有经历过我经历过的一些事情。我记得告诉我的孩子们，我说，我记得当我下城转火车到孟菲斯时，我会看到两个饮水机。有一个牌子写着，一个“白人”，一个“有色人种”。他们开始笑。他们会说，你真的看到了吗？那真的发生过？是的，那真的发生过。
So what I'm saying is that they've never experienced that, so they don't see things in the same prism that I see it. And so certainly they would be a little bit more excited, shall I say.
所以我说的是，他们从未经历过那一切，所以他们看待事物的棱镜和我看到的不一样。所以他们肯定会稍微兴奋一点，我应该这么说。
But it's interesting what you're saying, because you're saying that you feel like this is one more step. But when you talk to your grandkids or the young people in your church, you're saying they feel like, OK, the job's done, pretty much. There's a little tidying up around the edges, but they say we're way further along.
但这很有趣，因为你说你觉得这只是又迈出了一步。但当你和你的孙子们或者你教堂里的年轻人交谈时，你说他们觉得，好吧，工作已经完成了，差不多了。边缘还有点小事要整理，但他们说我们已经走得远多了。
Oh yeah, they-- oh man, this is it. He did it. And the door is wide open.
哦是的，他们——哦伙计，这就是了。他做到了。门大开了。
Now, do you think it's possible that they are more right and you are more wrong?
那么，你认为他们更有道理而你可能错了的可能性大吗？
I would hope they're more right, I would hope I'm more wrong, but I don't think so.
我希望他们更有道理，我希望是我错了，但我并不这么认为。
Reverend Donald Sharp of the Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church in Chicago.
芝加哥信心会幕浸信会教堂的唐纳德·夏普牧师。
Obama will change the world, Obama will change the world! Obama! Obama!
奥巴马将改变世界，奥巴马将改变世界！奥巴马！奥巴马！
These little kids on the West Side of Philadelphia on election day near a polling station. They made up the song themselves.
选举日那天，费城西区的一群小孩子在投票站附近。他们自己编了这首歌。
Obama! Obama! Obama!
奥巴马！奥巴马！奥巴马！
Act Three, Putting the Cart Before the Porsche. We end our show about have and have nots with this story about how the other half lives, the rich half, that is. This was recorded in front of a small, live audience in a theater in New York City. We are not going to mention the performer's name. And we're actually going to beep out the name of the town she's from to protect the privacy of her family. It's a pretty honest story.
第三幕，本末倒置。我们以关于另一半人——即富人那半——如何生活的故事结束关于富有者和贫困者的节目。这是在纽约市一家剧院的现场观众面前录制的。我们不会提到表演者的名字。为了保护她家人的隐私，我们甚至会消掉她家乡的名字。这是一个非常诚实的故事。
So my dad has this really annoying phrase that he uses as his blanket statement for everything. And that is, it's all about choices. It's all about choices, Sarah. You get a bad grade on a test? It's all about choices. Yeah, maybe I chose to hang out with my friends as opposed to studying for the test. I get it. You got a point. But he uses it all the time, for everything. It's like, Dad, my car got stolen. It's all about choices, Sarah. I fell and I broke my tailbone. It's all about choices. Because, obviously, it's all my fault.
我爸爸有个非常烦人的短语，他把它当作解释一切的万能借口。那就是，“这全看你的选择”。“这全看你的选择，莎拉”。考试成绩不好？这全看你的选择。是的，也许我选择了和朋友出去玩而不是复习考试。我明白了。你有道理。但他总是用它，对任何事情都用。就像，“爸爸，我的车被偷了。”“这全看你的选择，莎拉。”“我摔倒摔断了尾骨。”“这全看你的选择。”因为，显然，全都是我的错。
I think this phrase-- I actually know this phrase-- was born on a weeknight, during the autumn of 1990. Now, the first 12 years of my life, I lived in a upscale neighborhood in the suburbs of Virginia. My dad, he's a lawyer with his own practice. He's got a glittery bass fishing boat, which may not mean anything to all of you, but down there, it's a big deal. He's got a beautiful housewife and four perfect children. Most perfect, right here.
我想这个短语——我实际上知道这个短语——是在1990年秋天的一个平日晚上诞生的。在我生命的前12年，我住在弗吉尼亚州郊区的一个高档社区。我爸爸，是个有自己律所的律师。他有一艘闪闪发光的钓鱼艇，这对你们所有人可能意味着什么，但在那里，这是件大事。他有一个漂亮的家庭主妇和四个完美的孩子。最完美的那个，就在这儿。
And the picture becomes complete because my mom and my dad both have their own Porsche. But my dad has the classic 911. My mom has the sporty, fierce 928. And my mom's license plate, of course, MOMS928.
画面变得完整了，因为我妈妈和我爸爸都有自己的保时捷。但我爸爸有经典的911。我妈妈有运动型、凶猛的928。我妈妈的车牌，当然是，MOMS928。
My mom was not the one to pack your lunch. She was not the one to show up at your PTA meeting. She would wear her expensive jewelry to the pool. This is how she was. But are we going to line up in our Laura Ashley dresses at the Junior Women's Cotillion Holly Ball and the Miller & Rhoads white gloves in party manner and etiquette school? Yes. Yes, we are. And we did.
我妈妈不是那种给你准备午餐的人。她不是那种出现在家长会上的人。她会戴着昂贵的珠宝去游泳池。她就是这样。但我们要不要穿着Laura Ashley的连衣裙，戴着Miller & Rhoads的白手套，在初级妇女舞会和派对礼仪学校排队？是的。是的，我们会去。我们也确实去了。
Now, that was what it looked like on the outside. On the inside, it was not an environment of excess, but one of constraint. Rules were very important. Etiquette, very important. And my dad's insane temper could be set off by the slightest offense. When I heard the Porsche rumble up the driveway every day when he came home, I would run into my room and hide. Because maybe today would be the day that he found the candy wrapper in the sofa cushion and make my mom spank someone.
现在，那是外表看起来的样子。在内部，这不是一个充裕的环境，而是一个约束的环境。规则非常重要。礼仪，非常重要。而我爸爸疯狂的脾气会被最轻微的冒犯点燃。每天他开车回家时，当我听到保时捷在车道上轰鸣，我会跑进房间躲起来。因为也许今天就是他发现沙发垫里有糖果包装纸，让妈妈打别人屁股的那一天。
Or maybe today would be the day that he grabs me by the shoulder and yells at me for language. Because language, in my house, was very important. I mean, curse words, in my house, were extreme. We were not allowed to say gee-- golly gee-- because it sounded like you were about to say Jesus. Unacceptable, not out of a morality standpoint, but out of a, sort of like, we don't want our kids to be trash. OK? Only trash says, golly gee. What? I don't understand.
或者也许今天就是他抓住我的肩膀因为语言问题对我大吼大叫的那一天。因为语言，在我的家里，非常重要。我是说，诅咒，在我的家里，是极端的。我们不允许说“gee”——“golly gee”——因为它听起来像你要说“Jesus”。不可接受，不是从道德角度，而是从，某种程度上，我们不想让我们的孩子成为垃圾。好的吧？只有垃圾才会说“golly gee”。什么？我不明白。
But they could be very loving, very fun. I know, it's like, what? They could be fun, they could be spontaneous. But it was just all about avoiding awakening the bee's nest.
但他们可以非常可爱、非常有趣。我知道，就像，什么？他们可以很有趣，他们可以很自发。但这一切都只是为了避免惊动蜂巢。
So it all came to a screeching halt one night in 1990. I was 12 years old. I'm in my room. I'm rehearsing my lines for the school musical, which is an incarnation of the comic strip, Hagar the Horrible. I played the pivotal role of Viking Number Three. And my mom comes in the room, and her face is ashen. And she says, we are having a family meeting. Meet in the den.
所以这一切在1990年的一个晚上戛然而止。我12岁。我在房间里。我正在排练学校音乐剧的台词，那是漫画《哈格尔的烦恼》的化身。我扮演了海盗三号的核心角色。我妈妈走进房间，她的脸灰白。她说，我们要开个家庭会议。在书房见面。
Now, we'd never had a family meeting before, OK? Family meetings were for kids whose parents were going to get divorced. That's what they were for. I watched enough TV to know. Enough kids at school-- their parents were getting divorced left and right. And kids whose parents were divorced were like they had some kind of disease. I did not want to associate with them. They were clearly-- they smelled funny, they were poor, they had to go live with their mom in [BLEEP] Park, which was the ghetto because the houses were closer together, and you couldn't have your own pool.
现在，我们以前从来没开过家庭会议，好吗？家庭会议是给那些父母要离婚的孩子开的。那就是它们的用途。我看的电视足够多了，我知道。学校里足够多的孩子——他们的父母左一个右一个地离婚。父母离婚的孩子就像得了什么病一样。我不想和他们混在一起。他们显然——闻起来怪怪的，他们很穷，他们不得不去[消音]公园和妈妈住在一起，那是贫民窟，因为房子建得太近了，你不能有自己的游泳池。
So we go into the den, which is sort of like a men's parlour, with wood paneling and plaid furniture. It's very manly and dark. And my sister's in there. She has magically appeared from her college several hours away. So now I'm like, divorce, divorce, divorce, divorce. My dad looks really bad. Divorce, divorce, divorce, divorce.
所以我们进了书房，那里有点像男人的客厅，有木镶板和格子家具。它非常男性化且昏暗。我姐姐在里面。她神奇地从几个小时车程外的大学出现了。所以现在我像，“离婚，离婚，离婚，离婚。”我爸爸看起来很糟糕。“离婚，离婚，离婚，离婚。”
My mom speaks first. We're not getting a divorce. Like she knew. Whew, yes, I do not have to become a latchkey kid. And then she's like, but Dad-- Dad has something he wants to tell you. My dad starts to weep openly. And any elation about the non-divorce has now turned to complete dread.
我妈妈先说话了。“我们不是要离婚。”就像她知道一样。“呼，是的，我不必成为钥匙链小孩了。”然后她说，“但爸爸——爸爸有话想告诉你。”我爸爸开始公开哭泣。对不离婚的任何欣喜现在都变成了完全的恐惧。
So he finally gets the words out. Daddy did something bad. I took money that wasn't mine. And tomorrow I'm going to turn myself in. And I don't know what's going to happen.
所以他终于说出了那些话。“爸爸做了坏事。我拿了不属于我的钱。明天我要去自首。我不知道会发生什么。”
Boom! My brother's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. He's like 16. He's an ass [BLEEP]. Whoa, whoa, back up, back up. You mean-- what do you mean, you took money that wasn't yours? Like stealing? My dad's like, yes, what I did was like stealing.
砰！我弟弟就像，“哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。”他大概16岁。他是个混蛋[消音]。“哇，哇，等等，退后，退后。你的意思是——你拿了不属于你的钱是什么意思？像偷东西吗？”我爸爸就像，“是的，我做的事就像偷东西。”
Hey, OK, OK, OK. Was it like stealing, or was it stealing, Dad? You either stole or you didn't. So they press him. My brother presses him for more information.
“嘿，好的，好的，好的。是像偷东西，还是这就是偷东西，爸爸？你要么偷了要么没偷。”所以他们逼问他。我哥哥逼他提供更多信息。
So he tells us that when he was first starting out in law, a young couple had a newborn child that was mentally retarded. It's just-- I'm sorry. This is, like, so intense for me to even tell you this. I've never told anybody this. This newborn child was mentally retarded, and they believed it was the hospital's fault.
所以他告诉我们，当他刚开始从事法律工作时，一对年轻夫妇有个新生儿患有精神迟滞。这只是——对不起。这对我来说，哪怕说出来也太强烈了。我从来没告诉过任何人这个。这个新生儿是精神迟滞的，他们认为那是医院的错。
So my dad took the case pro bono. And he worked his butt off. He's like that ad on the subway, like, we fight for injured children. And there's a little leprechaun with boxing gloves on him. That's my dad, all right? So he gets it. And his case was so great that the hospitals decided to settle out of court. And a large sum of money was put into a trust fund for said retarded child. When you're the trustee of a trust fund, that means you can write checks out of the trust fund. AKA, you are entrusted with the money. OK?
所以我爸爸免费接了这个案子。他竭尽全力。他就像地铁上的那个广告，像，“我们为受伤的孩子战斗。”上面有个戴着拳击手套的小妖精。那就是我爸爸，好吗？所以他赢了。他的案子太棒了，以至于医院决定庭外和解。一大笔钱被存入了这个所谓的迟滞儿童的信托基金。当你是一个信托基金的受托人时，这意味着你可以从信托基金开支票。也就是说，钱托管给你了。好吗？
So many years after this happened, my dad decided, I'm just going to write myself a check out of this trust fund. And at first, it was just a little bit. And he thought, I'll put it back. No one will ever know. But then a little bit became a lot. And it got out of control. Because he had to pay for those Porsches and the house that goes on forever. And so he tells us all this, and he ends by saying, and we're going to start over. We are going to rebuild our lives.
所以在这件事发生多年后，我爸爸决定，“我只是要从这个信托基金给自己开一张支票。”起初，只是一点点。他想，“我会还回去的。没人会知道。”但后来一点点变成了很多。它失控了。因为他必须为那些保时捷和永无止境的房子买单。所以他告诉我们所有这一切，最后他说，“我们将重新开始。我们将重建我们的生活。”
And I'm over here, who gives a [BLEEP]? What does this have to do with me? And how am I going to help rebuild this family? I'm 12. All right?
我在这里想，这有什么大不了的？这和我有什么关系？我怎么帮着重建这个家庭？我才12岁。好吗？
So my mom's like, we recommend that you all stay home from school tomorrow, and we can work this out as a family. And I stood up, and I'm like, no. This is just perfect. You always make big announcements before the school play, the night before the school play. Grandaddy died the night before The Wizard of Oz. Here we go again. This always happens. Don't you people get it? When you miss school, you're not allowed to participate in the after-school activities. I hate you. I ran off.
所以我妈妈说，“我们建议你们所有人明天别去上学，我们可以作为一个家庭解决这个问题。”我站起来，就像，“不。这简直太完美了。你们总是在学校演出前，演出前一天晚上搞大宣布。爷爷在《绿野仙踪》前一天晚上去世了。又来了。总是这样。你们这些家伙不明白吗？当你缺课时，你就不被允许参加课后活动。我恨你们。”我跑开了。
So basically, what happened, I realized, it kind of was a big deal. Everybody at school knows that my dad's a bank robber. And they're calling me one. They think that I am come from a band of thieves and I'm not to be trusted. My parents lose all their friends. We have to move to the ghetto in [BLEEP] Park, which actually is a very nice neighborhood.
所以基本上，发生了什么，我意识到，这确实是一件大事。学校里的每个人都知道我爸爸是个银行抢劫犯。他们管我叫银行抢劫犯。他们认为我来自一个盗贼团伙，不值得信任。我的父母失去了所有的朋友。我们不得不搬到[消音]公园的贫民窟，那实际上是一个非常好的社区。
They didn't press charges. The family, amazingly, just said, hey, pay it back. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] My dad basically went from a lawyer to being, like, a paralegal. He was disbarred. It was terrible. My mom started doing odd jobs. She changed sheets at a nursing home and was the janitor in our Baptist Church. And it was a free-for-all in my house. Like, what was once very controlled was now like, whatever. Do what you want, Sarah. See you, we're going to go find ourselves.
他们没起诉。那家人，令人惊讶的是，只是说，“嘿，还回来。”[听不清] 我爸爸基本上从律师变成了，像，律师助理。他被剥夺了律师资格。这太可怕了。我妈妈开始做零工。她在疗养院换床单，是我们浸信会教堂的清洁工。家里发生了大混乱。就像，曾经受到严格控制的东西现在就像，“随便吧。想做什么就做什么，莎拉。再见，我们要去找我们自己了。”
But my dad was instantly better. He was a better person. He was happy. He chewed gum, which didn't happen before. And he wasn't such an a-hole all the time. And Mom, her transformation was amazing. She basically, just had this deep need in herself to recognize need and suffering in other people. And one day, she just went downtown and packed some bagged lunches-- that she never packed for me-- and took them to some homeless people living under a bridge, which turned into this huge charity, and she helped thousands of people who needed her help.
但我爸爸瞬间变好了。他成了一个更好的人。他很开心。他嚼口香糖，这以前没发生过。而且他也不总是那么个混蛋。我妈妈，她的改变令人惊讶。她基本上，内心深处有种深深的渴望去识别他人的需求和痛苦。有一天，她只是去了市中心，打包了一些袋装午餐——她从来没给我打包过——带给了住在大桥下的一些无家可归者，这演变成了这个巨大的慈善活动，她帮助了数千名需要她帮助的人。
And she went to Rwanda during the genocide. And she even let a homeless guy named Earl live with us once. He was a fugitive. We figured it out later. But who are we to judge? I mean, who are we to judge, really?
她在种族灭绝期间去了卢旺达。她甚至让一个叫厄尔的无家可归的人和我们住在一起。他是逃犯。我们后来才发现。但我们是谁去评判呢？我是说，我们是谁去评判呢，真的？
So finally, we never talked about it after that. Except once, my mom and I, about a year ago, were driving around, killing some time before her chemo treatment. And we went to the house that goes on forever. We wanted to see it. And it was very sad looking. And the grass was dead. And it was kind of crumbling.
所以最后，我们再也没谈过这件事。除了有一次，大约一年前，我妈妈和我在她化疗前开车四处转转，消磨时间。我们去了那座永无止境的房子。我们想看看它。它看起来非常悲伤。草都枯死了。它有点摇摇欲坠。
And we stopped, and I asked her, Mom-- I don't even know why I said it-- Mom, why did Dad turn himself in? And she said, well, your sister wrote him a letter from college that said she loved him and was proud of him and wanted to be a lawyer. And I came home and found him sobbing in the fetal position on the floor. And he said to me, I can't do this anymore. I've made all the wrong choices. And now I'm ready to make a right one. And then he confessed, and he told us that night.
我们停下车，我问她，“妈——我甚至不知道我为什么这么说——妈，爸爸为什么去自首？”她说，“嗯，你姐姐从大学写了一封信给他，说她爱他，为他感到骄傲，想成为一名律师。我回家发现他在地板上缩成胎儿姿势哭泣。他对我说，‘我再也做不到这个了。我做出的全都是错误的选择。现在我准备做出一个正确的了。’然后他坦白了，那天晚上他告诉了我们。”
So my mom told me this, and then we sat there in silence. And I said, it's all about choices. And we laughed.
所以我妈妈告诉我这些，然后我们在沉默中坐了一会儿。我说，“这全看你的选择。”我们笑了。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Seth Lind and P.J. Vogt. Music help from Jessica Hopper. [ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS] This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. [FUNDING CREDITS] WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who described his philosophy of broadcasting this way.
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、莎拉·凯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。Seth Lind和P.J. Vogt提供了制作帮助。Jessica Hopper提供了音乐帮助。[致谢] 《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。[资金鸣谢] WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，Torey Malatia先生负责，他这样描述他的广播理念。
Everything must be charming. And you don't allow the ugly.
一切必须是迷人的。而你不能允许丑陋。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。